les reçus regardez c'est là dedans
qu'est ce qu'on a dans ben bassat
regarder mais les recevoir à l'instant
alors nouveau samsung galaxy s 22 plus
on en parle dans quelques jours pour
l'instant ce sont sur celui là c'est le
f 22 est rare qu'est ce qu'on va faire
ici qu'est ce qu'on va regarder c'est
vraiment un tout début c'est une prise
en main c'est une découverte on va le
prendre je vais l'ouvrir très rapidement
le nom boxing va être très très rapide
on se le fait on va partir dans la rue
on va regarder ce qu'on peut faire parce
qu'on vend plein de choses on vend de la
nato graphie donc des photos de nuit des
vidéos de nuit sublime et on vend des
superbes photos des très belles vidéos
donc je vais prendre un truc qui est
dans le placard regardez juste là je
vais prendre lui ou lui ces jo bhi qui
m'a filé sa merci joby on va prendre un
des deux et on va mettre le smartphone
dessus et on va partir dans la rue on va
commencer à regarder c'est une première
découverte on va regarder si c'est
intéressant on va regarder ce que ça
raconte en termes de photos en terme de
vidéo la stabilisation d'un double
téléobjectif x 3 x 10 enfin bref si vous
connaissez pas la fiche technique du
galaxy s 22 ultra et bien je vous
renvoie ma vidéo de présentation parce
que je vous explique tout le style et
compagnie donc on fera une autre vidéo
plus tard on va vraiment parler de
productivité on va regarder on peut
venir faire avec ce style et les usages
mais là c'est vraiment un premier jet
qui m'intéresse vraiment pour toute la
partie photo et vidéo pour voir vraiment
parce que les promesses à sont tellement
dingue voir si elles sont tenues donc ça
c'est vraiment très gros focus qui est
fait là dessus mais justin on va
s'ouvrir mais d'abord fait quoi d'un
petit générique
regardez déjà vous voyez c'est très plat
c'est très plat ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'on va plus de blocs de
charge à l'intérieur et ça je vous
l'expliquais il ya un autre truc qu'on
n'a pas à l'intérieur et je voulais dire
également lors de la vidéo présentation
et bien on a plus d'écouteurs c'est la
première année ses débuts en tout cas
que les constructeurs ne sont plus
obligés en france de mettre des
écouteurs filaires donc si vous le
voulez lui et bien vous pouvez avoir les
samsung les galaxy besson lors des
offres de prêt comme vous le recommande
réellement pour avoir des petits
écouteurs offert il ya une valeur
marchande on vous prend votre ancien
smartphone à sa valeur + 150 euros donc
c'est plutôt pas mal et c'est à durée
limitée donc ne tardez pas trop regarder
on va s'ouvrir très rapidement à ce qui
a déjà été ouverte côté samsung j'ai pas
l'impression en maître sur des petites
des petites feuilles il est quand même
extrêmement classe regardez je n'ai pas
encore touché cette couleur est vraiment
très très belle seimat c'est sobre le
bloc photo est intégré mais d'une façon
qui est juste magnifique c'est vraiment
extrêmement beau alors après c'est un
smartphone qui est très massif en termes
de prise en regard des lâches et je fais
le tour il est très très grand on va
regarder aussi le confort là comment il
tient dans la poche est ce qu'il est
lourd paour super beau vite fait voyons
voir ce qui a ensuite à l'intérieur il
ya des petits c'est quoi les petits
autocollants quelques chaînes on s'en
fiche on trouve quoi ben là dedans je
vais à mon cordon en fait je pense mon
petit diable et puis c'est tout quoi
j'ai mis un petit cordon ici en usb
c'est pour mieux recharger vos ya plus
d'écouteurs donc ça permet d'avoir des
boîtes un peu plus réduite bon ok donc
on va se le prendre on va se tester on
part dans la rue on part en expédition
autour de cette vidéo sur deux jours
l'as lattes ont tout de suite il est
quoi et 17h la nuit commence légèrement
à tomber je tendrai la partie deux jours
tout à l'heure je vais partir là je vais
aller faire des photos côté un peu nuit
puis on va regarder ce que ça raconte et
si s'intéressant aux est prêt on y va je
vous montre les photos les premières
photos prises ici avec le il est là
rédélé juste là le galaxy s 22 ultra
alors on se prend un tel détail un peu
plus tard de regarder déjà les premières
photos c'est vachement vachement
intéressant alors que j'ai commencé par
la nuit savez c'est y mettre vraiment
l'accent sur la nuit la night au logis
on va regarder ça alors là ya les photos
et juste après je vous montre les vidéos
comme ça vous allez barre donc ça
regardez ça c'est les photos nuit alors
celle de la gelée un peu raté je pense
parce que on est quand même sur le
grand-angle et vous allez voir que le
reste est plutôt pas mal ça c'est
l'ultra grand angle on peut venir se
rapprocher l'institut noté ça c'est un
zoom x 3 et on va jusqu'en x 10 ans nuit
on peut pas aller au delà sinon on n'est
plus dans le menu donc là j'ai vraiment
fait des photos avec le mode nuit on va
quand même regard des hommes sur le faut
dit on voit quand même un résultat qui
est plutôt bien donc on continue comme
ça regardez je trouve superbe et vous
allez voir que toutes les photos prises
avec votre capteur sans 8 mégapixels en
condition de nuit en photo nuit c'est
juste magnifique on a tous au niveau des
lumières on a une ambiance on a une
super bonne gestion je trouve vraiment
très très très belle même pareil la
voyons des biens les nuages enfin il ya
il ya un très gros boulot à dos
rythmique avec du matos derrière qui
fonctionne donc super beau boulot ici de
samsung l'ultra grand temps et ce sera
forcément moins précis et en conditions
de faible luminosité c'est normal et
même sur une bonne nuit même si vous
allez voir qu'on arrive à sortir des
choses et puis ensuite fera trois bons
saleh à l'ehpad mais y en aura d'autres
et le faux 10 faut vraiment pas que ça
bouge en condition de nuit caméra
belle-fille la nuit je suis pas
convaincu vraiment pas vous allez le
voir également sur plusieurs photos il
ya celle là j'ai essayé dans différentes
conditions avec différentes conditions
de lumière à droite et à gauche et on
retrouve quand même regardé un peu de
bruit même là derrière en arrière-plan
c'est pas extraordinaire et voilà donc
ça c'est la caméra principale on reçoit
yves sur l' ultra grand-angle ans c'est
pareil sinon faut pas que ça bouge à moi
je bouge donc je suis désolé mais tout
de suite ça pardonne pas et c'est pas
ouf on vient faire un coût deux fois 3
un coup de feu disent bon là c'est pas
ou alors regarder l'art une fois de plus
on est sur les caméras principal c'est
plutôt bien on pas sur l'ultra grand
temps que j'ai recommencé j'ai voulu
vraiment le faire a pour retraités
luttera vente en vendant moins de
précision assez pas dingue pour peut
aller en x 3 x 3 il est quand même pas
mal on a comme bien regarder les petites
gouttes là sur le côté dans l'ensemble
c'est pas mauvais mais bon il faut
disent on va complètement oublier la
caméra de self il s'est trouvé vraiment
pas terrible parce que et je vais vous
tout de suite il ya un travail au niveau
il ya au niveau algorithmique lorsque je
me prends en photo je vois que je suis
un côté un peu une tête un peu naturel
de poids et tout de suite ça m'a plati
sam écrase avec un côté un peu dé
saturer et je vais envoyer il est plus
trop rouge alors qu'il est quand même
plutôt rouge c'est ce qu'on voit
el-assad et ça tu as donc ses
algorithmes icasa peut être mis à jour
mais même moi je me trouve très pâle et
je trouve que c'est pas beau et on voit
tout de suite avec la photo est faite il
ya un côté un peu d'imprécisions donc
photos demi c'est pas terrible alors
mode portrait avec gilles beck a pris la
pause je vous ai fait du mode portrait
j'en ai testé 2 3 le détourage est quand
même plutôt pas mal ça sera pas parfait
en termes de mode portrait de de ce que
je vois c'est vraiment les premières
photos celle là sera un petit peu mieux
ça c'était avec le x 3 parce qu'on va de
portraits g soit du fonds soit deux fois
trois ans fois c'est pas mal bon alors
après il y avait beaucoup d'éclairage
daria donc c'était un petit peu plus
compliqué pour lui il faut essayer sur
différentes scènes mais sur un premier
jet comme ça sur le foin c'est pas mal
de fois trois menus on va oublier la
caméra de celle fille puisse vous
l'armée ya un côté très désaturer c'est
pas parfait alors j'étais celle des
trucs dans le métro aussi bon on voit
c'est pas hyper ouf on peut se
rapprocher alors là je me fais du space
zoom x 100 dans le métro mais bon ça
pique les yeux on continue ici place de
la bastille ce que c'est vraiment bien
en règle générale et on le voit comme ça
ici au niveau de votre caméra principale
du travail entend regarder au niveau des
voitures sur le côté voilà c'est tout de
suite moins - ou fuck x 3 x 2 10 et
histoire de vous montrer mais bon une
fois de plus c'est pas au plus haut à
nice mais c'est très beau mais vous avez
un peu de lumière en conditions de
faible luminosité un capteur principal
de 100 8 mégapixels que le boulot est
vraiment vraiment vraiment bien faire
garder la seu ce soit vraiment vos
luttera grand-angle pas ouf on peut
commencer à se rapprocher un petit peu
en x 3 et là regardez là je suis venu
chercher davantage je pense que c'est
vraiment bien honnêtement je trouve x 10
là tout de suite pour que le résultat
est vraiment bien là j'ai bougé après
emploi 30 on oublie j'ai fait différents
tests avec différentes expos en mode
manuel stepanek là je vous emmène place
des vosges toujours à paris et regardez
c'est juste magnifique on a les reflets
des lumières ici dans les flaques d'eau
le ciel enfin voila je militais nuit
peine lui donc c'est vraiment beau une
fois de plus le très grand angle c'est
un peu moins ça mais bon on peut se
rapprocher un petit peu si on le veut
même question et x 3 x 10 mais c'est pas
voilà je me fais du space zoom regarder
ça joue un super beau jeu différente
celle en fait on va vraiment la
profondeur avec déjà le bâtiment ici on
a ensuite toute la partie derrière la
qui est super bien la gestion des
lumières c'est pareil là rien et
surexposé rien etc ramener tout et
maîtrise donc de travail algorithmique
et derrière il est vraiment très très
bon c'est moins ou fin une fois de plus
sur l'ultra grand temps que c'est moins
précis c'est moins beau ça bouge chez
voilà je suis peut-être que l'ultra
grand temps que sur un trépied c'est
bien mais c'est vraiment pris à la main
donc c'est joli c'est un premier jeu
donc on sera différent de choses le x 3
il quand même plutôt bien aussi j'aime
bien là dessus regardez là c'est pareil
on a bien les lampadaires là qui vont
pas baver c'est pas dégueu c'est très
beau on a bien le hier en dessous pour
voir qu on a différentes expos et bien
ça fonctionnera alors même qu'ils sont
sur lui très grand-angle voilà on peut
d'ailleurs approché voilà c'est pas ouf
le truc que samsung nous vend ici c'est
la night ogre achi c'est à dire la vidéo
de la photo de nuit et un gros boulot
qui a été fait l'a tueurs lancés
quelques petites est devenu je suis
place des vosges à paris on va regarder
alors c'est vraiment le début le début
du test on regardera ça plus tard mais
oui je voulais quand même connaissait
pas quelques petites images pour se
faire une idée de ce que ça pourrait
donner donc là je suis en train de
filmer sur le capteur principal à
l'arrière sur son 8 mégapixels même si
vous douterez que c'est prévu une vidéo
entre 8 mégapixels je fais mais là
dessus maintenant je vais pas si folle
ultra grand-angle et à mon avis ça va
piquer donc là je fasse sur l' ultra
grand-angle alors normalement celui là
en faible luminosité et surtout en vidéo
ce que j'y crois pas des masses un jeu
voilà je vous le dis mais on va regarder
ça vous vous le voyez moi je vois pas
encore l'âge de feux d'un côté parce que
sinon je vais rien c'est le
un tel objectif c'est le foie trois
voiliers lauriane stade lebon vraiment
pas moi je m'en rends compte parce que
j'entrais 6 mai y'a de la stalle ici
vous voyez
comme ça ça marche
stéphanie semaine un crédit global mans
j'ai pas fait pourquoi on va rien mais
on a la caméra de celle ci qui même si
là je vois tout de suite à l'image c'est
pas aux caméras ce qui s'est passé pour
septembre peut-être de plus un jour mais
là la nuit
puis l'âge et la vue du réalisateur où
je me voilà que les caméras de celle ci
est donc là je suis sur l' ultra
grand-angle et en europe la lutte ragon
temps le jeu peut switcher directement
voilà la forme en grand-angle et là je
me sens le téléobjectif sais pas où
comme ça le grand angle ultra
grand-angle qui est pas terrible
terrible mais là comme ça je pense que
c'est le genre le meilleur résultat avec
le mode du réalisateur où je peux avoir
les trucs comme ça je peux aussi faire
autrement
côte à côte comme ça avec la caméra de
seniors i banal ce mode c'est ce que
j'appelle le mode bp garcia ce qui
ferait ses vidéos pour le coup on a
vraiment comme ça donc là j'ai les deux
fichiers je peux encore faire
différemment alors j'ai un autre mode
mais pareil chez apple aveugle je me
rends pas compte ces portraits vidéo de
nuit donc portrait vidéo donné je sais
pas on va se tester tout ça en plein
jour on commence par la nuit sur te
faire une petite ambiance comme ça donc
je peux le faire enfin je peux le faire
aussi en x 3 x 3 h lorsque mise à parme
le film elle trouve n'est pas voir grand
chose voilà peu cher comme ça voilà dans
l'ensemble c'est vraiment très très bien
alors j'ai essayé d'avancer maximum la
jours à vannes en pleine journée là je
voulais mise parce que je trouvais ça
intéressant parce que là effectivement
il ya un très grand soleil donc là c'est
très différent des expos expo assez
forte là une expo un peu plus faible ici
parce qu'ils aient un peu d'ombré et
malgré tout on ressort même la voyait au
niveau du ler brienne et cramer tour
sens bien tout est bien exposé donc
super beau boulot ultra grand-angle de
plein jour ira tout de suite beaucoup
mieux et ça on le voit et ça c'est bien
donc plutôt bien on peut se rapprocher
là je dois l sur le x 30 et donc voilà
c'est le x 30 et on peut dire faire du
foie semble une fois de plus le
spacebook même si on a un processeur qui
karnakata domaine qui valait plus loin
en termes de capacités de calcul ça
reste pas où pareille la voyait au
niveau des différentes expos et bien ça
marche vraiment très très très très bien
en plein jour l'ultra grand temps que
donnera un bien meilleur rendu et c'est
là qu'on va vraiment venir tirer le
maximum 1 wallemme au niveau du ciel ça
marche bien je trouve qui a pas d'écart
a tout de suite pas d'écart de
colorimétrie de ce que je vois entre le
grand-angle et l'ultra grand temps dont
je trouve ça plutôt bien les mots niveau
du ciel dont ça c'est chouette bon là le
point il fsi sur la branche donc le
reste est un peu fou derrière mais sinon
c'est pas grave vient semer davantage
coface envie de faire que cette façon on
oublie tout l'ag pareil j'ai voulu
regarder les différentes expos avec le
soleil là et tout donc ça marche ultra
grand angle marge de plein jeu on peut
se rapprocher ok bon voilà toujours les
mêmes un peu les mêmes choses les
différentes expos je trouve que dans
l'ensemble c'est vraiment bien maîtrisé
alors là je les muscats l'amour j'ai
poussé vraiment fort avec le soleil là
et c'est très drôle parce que sur
l'écran je ne voyais pas et là je vois
quand même bien contours du soleil
plutôt pas mal je vois mon bâtiment ici
que je ne verrai pas en plein jour je ne
devrais pas avec mes yeux que même au
travers de l'écran du smartphone je ne
voyais pas je lis ce qui est écrit sur
les plaques la semaine presque venir
intéresse vous donner et se voit ce qui
est écrit donc non il ya vachement de
précisions donc ça c'est très très très
bien super beau boulot point de virer
gorille de luxe et c'est absolument
dingue l'ultra grand angle et quand même
pas mal on voit quand même ce qui se
passe on peut bien lire c'est vraiment
très très très très bien bosser ici on
vient se rapprocher une fois de plus
alors c'est pas de la magie non plus
mais on voit quand même les fenêtres en
haut ça c'est sûr deux fois 3 et si je
trouve ça super intéressant parce que
regarder il ya différentes expos ok on
va venir chercher la statue tout au fond
et on va dire progresser dans l'image on
commence par du travail entend l'on
prend un peu de recul et on veut ni bien
sûr le côté donc il n'ya pas de
déformation c'est très bien maîtrisée
d'un point de vue optique ici et là on
vient se rapprocher regarder on se
rapproche de la statue ça marche bien
alors ya un côté un peu lisse et mais
c'est très léger très très très léger
pour venir éviter d'apporter du bruit là
je suis sur x 30 c'est correct et bon le
foie sans voile assez gadget mais
regardez là le faut dit il est très bon
alors on est sur un double tel objectif
sur l'ultra on est sur un zoom optique x
3 et un zoom optique x 10 dont classe et
de l'optique c'est ça qui est
intéressant le tout la progression dans
les véhicules et ça c'est de l'optique
saas et de l'optique saas et de
l'optique ça c'est l'optique voilà et ça
c'est du zoom numérique donc plutôt
intéressant qu'est ce que j'ai ici donc
là la place des vosges vous aimez pareil
pouvons regarder à contre-jour ici
plutôt pas mal an les travaux s'étaient
pas ouf mais une fois de plus sans cesse
les différentes expos lutrin grand-angle
et bien je le trouve très très bien en
plein jour il ya beaucoup de lumière
c'est toujours ce qu'on va venir dès
qu'un ultra grand-angle mais d'un point
de vue général regardez là on voit bien
les façades là tout est bien maîtrisée
nan ça marche ça marche vraiment
vraiment vraiment voilà c'est un peu
toujours la même chose que je viendrai
vous dire ici mais je trouve que une
fois de plus samsung a très bien bossé
ici au niveau de la gestion avec l'ia
derrière au niveau des photos tout la
gestion des contre-jours est très bonne
à la différence du s20 il ya deux ans où
ça fait plus de problématiques au niveau
des hautes lumières est bien ici je ne
les retrouve pas dans différentes
conditions dans différentes expos je
peux venir pousser ça marche et je suis
vraiment vraiment vraiment satisfait
alors le mode portrait mais alors là
c'était complexe que c'était moi qu'une
paire j'enclenche je retourne et donc
n'étaient pas optimales vraiment on
commence à regarder il des tours très
bien sans aucun problème ça c'est une
mode portrait x 3 2 3 un peu moins bon
mais une fois de plus c'est moi qui le
prenaient qu'il faut ne faut pas
regarder un peu plus tard lorsqu on va
voir ce soir les phases de test on a
différents types de modes portrait bon
voilà je vous montre ça rapidement
l'appareil je voulais vraiment que la
garde et les hautes lumières parce que
si ça me semblait un poil cramé mais en
fait non parce qu'elle savait qu'ils
étaient très très fort c'était un peu la
limite lorsque vous voyez ça a bien
poussé très fort dans quelque chose qui
se réfléchit énormément mais regardez
comme dirait zoomer
ça fonctionne pas de souci là-dessus la
caméra que celle ci ne trouve pas
parfait qu'elle trouve vraiment en
dessous c'est dommage parce que s'il
arrive à nous faire une caméra c'est le
fait qu'il soit la hauteur de ce qu'on a
à l'arrière on aura un truc de dingue at
elle convoque un peu d'espacé au niveau
de l'optique dans cette zone là c'est
beaucoup plus plat on va moins jouer sur
la profondeur ou que même sur les poses
c'est c'est moins beau alors ça dépend
j'ai changé voyez un petit peu donc
celle là je la trouve un peu mieux un
peu plus contrastée au niveau de la peau
j'ai voulu tester en fait c'est
intéressant parce que lorsque je
regardais une fois de plus un vous avez
un grand ciel bleu est bien la cible ans
je voyais rien à l'écran là c'est pareil
c'était tout cramé et bien je trouve que
d'un point de vue algorithmique là c'est
vraiment que l'algorithme qui bossent
vous récupère bien une bonne expo niveau
du visage vous avez un côté ombre et
donc ça écrase pas trop c'est pas mal
mais on voit ce qui est au dessus alors
on a à la même qualité que ce qu'on
aurait sur les caméra arrière qui
viendra mieux compenser parce que
l'optique sera meilleur mais malgré tout
d'un point de vue algorithmique ça
fonctionne et lorsque je me prends de
l'autre côté aussi ça fonctionne donc
c'est plutôt bien voyons cherche les
différentes expos et dans l'ensemble ça
marche maintenant que ce que je retrouve
ici en photo sur un premier jet je
trouve que en conditions de faible
luminosité
c'est pas parfait sauf sur la caméra
principale et on peut venir ou non un
peu mais pas trop de plein jour se
trouve que le boulot est vraiment bien
fait jusqu'à un zoom optique x 10 bien x
30 on peut y aller au delà on oublie
mais malgré tout il ya un super boulot
et maintenant on va regarder toute la
partie vidéo un jour amène place des
vosges en plein jour là on se met dans
une zone d'ombré le soleil et de l'autre
côté là bas vous voyez derrière a coûté
éclairé donc si c'est ce qu'ils font des
travaux un très beau mais bon là la
place un travail magnifique donc là on
regarde dans la zone d'ombré ce que ça
raconte avec les lumières d'arrière la
stabilisation au regard si ça fonctionne
bien on va se mettre au soleil en tête
est archi plein de tests c'est vraiment
un premier jet 1 mais permet de se
rendre compte un peu et ça c'est plutôt
bien donc là on est sur le grand-angle
normal on passe sur l'ultra grand-angle
vers des voiliers montre je vois pas moi
je suis vraiment la bagarre donc devenir
en découvrir ça après hop là
regardez on change là on a la lumière
derrière donc pour l'instant besoin de
dons mais il fait super beau aujourd'hui
donc c'est quand même vachement cool
alors avec le x 3 tenu à la main et
quand même une bonne stabilisation de
regarder le x 3 ça c'est vous fin je
pense qu'il faut vraiment le poser après
sur un piège en sait rien alors comment
ils sont venus [ __ ] en optique va
forcément c'est tout de suite plutôt pas
mal oui là je tiens facile de marcher un
peu avec s'est pas trop fait on doit je
le vois l'image c'est vraiment pris pour
déplacer le plus fait pour être posé sur
un plan plan fixe là on est sur le faux
10 un petit trois structures sur un
téléobjectif longtemps laissé les sétois
un truc alors les petits pigeons là qui
est en train de se moquer il ya un bon
traitement logiciel a quand même c'est
pas mal
là bas on regarde déjà du soleil sur la
place des vosges
de ce que je vois à l'écran c'est pas
mal ensuite en franchement et lancer la
caméra de celle ci comme ça je me vois
alors moi je tremble donc forcément sur
la paille à l'histoire et jouera là que
ça bouge au niveau au niveau des arbres
si vous avez la main solide et qui ne
bouge pas ça devrait pouvoir le faire
moi j'ai pas hyper convaincu la par
cette caméra de salfit tête reposée sur
un pied ou en mode du réalisateur comme
je vous ai montré en condition de nuit
mais bon là je le tiens de mon histoire
d'être sûr que ça bouge absolument pas
mais bon et derrière la contre jour ah
ça crame d'arrière où la houlala que sa
trame derrière bon c'est pas normal donc
donc là en ce moment' le soleil
travaille derrière ça devrait aller
mieux comme ça au lieu de s'attaquer
aujourd'hui
donc je pense que là normalement sur le
grand-angle en plein soleil ça devrait
être pas mal de faire donc je vous
laisse juger à vous nous dites en
commentaire
on se teste maintenant un côté ultra
grand-angle il ya un mec là bas qui est
en train de faire de sport de combat
contre les arbres c'est très étrange je
vais vous montrer on a testé le crédit
objectif là le regarder ça voilà ça
telle ultra grand-angle donc ça c'est le
x 3 qui sont en train de refaire les
fontaines en fait je pense à tout de
suite un travail sur les fontaines ici
donc ça c'est du x 3 x 3 petits os x
donc en regard d'un loyer
si je lui mets le soleil en pleine face
donc c'est pas mal quand même s'en sort
et puis là on passe sur 9 10 le
regardait ce que vous voyez le monsieur
vaillant font la malle
qui est en train de
je pense qu'il est un peu lui-même suis
allé entretien donc voilà
qu'à plus de femmes à stabiliser sa
ceyrac si bien
voyez on a le le point de collecte de
sapins cayla le point se fait très bien
on passe d'un point là regardez là au
fond au point plus proche hop c'est très
rapide ça va bien et puis la caméra
celle fille en plein soleil voilà une
fois de la lumière de façon à celle là
pareil pour la stab je tiens vraiment à
demain parce que sinon j'ai l'impression
que ça peut le faire mais sinon ça a
l'air plutôt bien dans l'ensemble même
là au niveau du contre-jour ça a pas
l'air mauvais dit - vraiment ce que vous
en pensez vous directement mais comme ça
ce que je son écran tout casser à pas
mal là je vous fais une vue du
réalisateur en plein jour avec un ma
caméra de s'expliquer planqué rapide
derrière vous avez le grand angle assez
efficace a quand même extrêmement
efficace et puis ce qui est génial c'est
que en live alors je voulais montrer
encore dix ans et demi mais je veux pas
qu'on est en plein jour et moi je peux à
plat c'est passé un peu chaque film et
ça change quoi inciter à sa charge
objectif à plat coucou apple regardez
tac je souris tu peux me rapprocher
ça c'est vachement bien bon alors c'est
dommage que ces travaux là et puis des
poubelles il va me trouver ici mais
sinon le spot l'espagne toujours
toujours magnifique à dix on peut venir
se rapprocher un peu une autre
affirmation que sur le grand-angle face
à foix iii et enfin 10 peut pas passer
sur du très grand pas pourquoi mais ça
permet de voir des choses c'est un mal
voilà très gadget sais pas si ça que
vous pouvez utiliser vous ça mais bon ça
la série all en tout cas où ça tape le
soleil alors c'est la vidéo portrait sur
la caméra de celle ci je ne sais pas si
ça va être enfin ça j'ai vraiment envie
de voir mr pour pouvoir m'en rendre
compte mais si on l'a sur l'écran de
l'ordinateur comme le soleil qui
l'accompagnent seront massés passants de
sa rencontre à près de 20 qui tombe
comme ça ce qui continue je regarde
comme santa fe curieux sa paire mauvais
par rapport à ce que l'on avait une
époque sur les vidéos portrait et là je
suis sur la caméra de celle fille ça
c'est quoi ça fait noir de pouvoir
changer des choses un largage un flou
l'ag quoi cercle je peux changer en live
en fait point de couleur lynch barre des
6000 à son cercle je peux réduire ou
augmenter à fond ça c'est drôle ça qu'en
le faisant direct alors je suis sur
cette caméra c'est dommage mais sinon
j'ai l'impression que pour une fois ça
marche bien et que là alors à vérifier
vous me le dites parce que moi je me
rends pas compte tout de suite et pour
une fois ça a l'air pas mal donc là on
est sur la caméra celle fillon reste à
faire c'est vrai caméra arrière voilà
sur la caméra arrière je pense que la
stalle va être mieux alors j'ai
complètement aveugle à je ne vois pas on
va vérifier tout ça en post prod mais
sans le croatie ça a l'air pas mal et
surtout ça monte un truc qui est
vachement intéressant c'est la puissance
de l'exil aux 2200 à la mesure où ça
marche bien de plus je regarde mais vous
vous le voyez comme ça vous le savez
directement mais si ça c'est concluant
ça veut dire que la puissance de calcul
derrière elle est énorme et qu'à mon
avis ça va le faire à mandailles ok
alors là je triche je le pose sur une
poubelle en fait vous ne voyez pas
pourquoi parce que je trouvais que à la
main ça tremblait un maximum ça veut
dire quoi ça ça veut dire que en fait et
bien le processeur il n'arrive pas à
stabiliser façon électronique peut pas
tout calculé en fait calculés et le flou
que vous allez à bord et calcule la
stagnation d'un point de vue chronique
donc la salle a été vraiment pourri à la
main donc le mode vidéo portrait si vous
bougez pas si vous mettez sur un trépied
ça ira donc ça calcule bien et ça c'est
vachement bien déjà parce qu'il ya trop
vouloir aller je peux bouger donc ça
c'est cool mais par contre si vous le
tenez à la main joue on verra avec les
france gravés en 32 nanomètres si on
peut il tenir à la main et avoir une
vraie vidéo portrait proverbe bon soyons
clairs le mode portrait vidéo non ça va
pas alors qu'il est vraiment poussé fort
j'ai vraiment fait exprès mais on le
voit quand je bouge on le voit sur le
côté que le résultat est pas d'un
guépard processeur capacités de calcul
malgré le gpu derrière ça veut pas dire
que le gpu sera pas mon sur la party
gaming à mon avis il le sera et là
dessus il y aura pas de souci mais en
attendant c'est ce qu'on voit c'est que
le mode portrait vidéo même encore
aujourd'hui avec des progrès vers catane
aurait très bien ça marche
faut pas bouger mais c'est pas le but de
la vidéo la vidéo faut bouger donc non
voilà tout ce que je voulais vous
montrer c'est un premier jet c'est
vraiment premier geste sur ce samsung
galaxy s 22 ultra on se reparlera ce
smartphone on va le tester davantage et
puis n'oubliez pas qu'il teste qui va
arriver du s22 plus est complet on va se
faire un test complet aussi le médecin
de l'ultra je voulais vraiment partager
avec vous cette première prise en main
première expérience photo parce que la
gamme mais c'est la partie photo vidéo
il ya également toute la partie
productivité qui est venu sur ce modèle
ultra avec l'arrivée du spn donc la
partie productivité bien on cela regarde
dans quelques jours on va ce check et
tout ça probablement également avec un
combo productivité avec la samsung
galaxy la table et suite ultra va
regarder ça gave plein de choses à
raconter donc si vous n'êtes pas abonné
venez vous abonner puis si vous avez des
questions ou interrogations suggestions
j'y répondrai lors du test global qui
arrivera très prochainement d'ici là
prenez soin de vous de cendres à du gros
bisous on est beaucoup d'amour chaos
[Musique]